joining me now is south carolina senator
lindsey graham senator
good to see you tonight the only thing
that biden seems
to be able to rally the world around is
at this point just undermining america
and talking about how we're all
systemically racist
yeah i mean you know let's just be
honest uh the bad guys were
afraid of trump who's afraid of biden i
mean
you know the europeans are talking about
doing a trade deal with china
as china dismantles hong kong's
democracy
and is engaging in genocide against the
uyghurs
so this just blows my mind they're
talking about going back into the
iranian nuclear deal
even though iran hasn't changed its
behavior at all i can tell you one thing
the israelis miss miss a strong american
president
the mexican president blamed biden for
the spike in illegal immigration
we've had 160 increase in illegal
immigration
uh in the last six months because biden
doesn't know what he's doing on the
border
well here are the big issues that biden
thinks he can rally europe around
watch 80 years ago
prime minister winston churchill and
president franklin roosevelt
signed an agreement today we build on
that commitment
with a revitalized atlantic charter
speaking directly
to the key the key challenges of this
century
cyber security emerging technologies
global health and climate change
he talked about an international
rules-based order quite different from
what winston churchill was talking about
all those years ago senator
well let me give you two examples we've
had two
cyber attacks on our economy coming from
russian territory by russian
organizations i think are given
a pass by the russian government they're
probably working together to be honest
with you
and you've had growing evidence that the
coronavirus came out of a lab in china
not
nature and is biden asking the europeans
to do anything to push back against
russian cyber terrorism
is he even talking about what should we
do to reign china
in no this is just all fluff
and happy talk i miss trump
well senator you argue in a new op-ed
that
early and near-total dismissal of the
lab leak theory played a prominent role
in trump's defeat in 2020 in the
presidential race explain
well okay in february uh 2020 27
american scientists
wrote a a an op-ed saying that anybody
who suggested the lab
the coronavirus came out of the chinese
lab is a right-wing nut
then later on five other scientists said
the same thing
why is that important if in fact the
coronavirus came out of the chinese lab
like a lot of people suspected
people in america would be outraged and
want somebody to take it to china
that would have been the biggest issue
in the entire campaign
who can make china pay for infecting the
world secondly by shutting down this
legitimate question about where the
coronavirus came from
they reinforced the idea that trump was
a nut
so the scientists who signed that letter
in february 2020 i got a question for
them what evidence did you have
to make you feel so strong there was no
other alternative than
it coming from nature was this a
political document or a scientific
document to dr fauci
i'm not challenging science i'm
questioning the motive of the scientist
who definitively said in february 2020
a lab league was a right-wing conspiracy
idea
well why did they say that they're tied
to the wuhan lab
they have a self-interest to shut down
that inquiry i think it changed the 2020
election i really well it obviously did
i mean
i'm so i don't say it's obvious but it
100
did as did the dismissal dismissal of
all
these early treatments and just blowing
them off saying oh they don't work it
turns out now
of course this big study about
hydroxychloroquine just published
uh 200 increase in survival if it's used
with zinc and
azithromycin uh and so all these
people's lives could have been saved but
anthony fauci and the medical
cartel as we call them dismissed it and
trashed the motives
of president trump and any of us who
interviewed the top experts who said it
worked
outrageous that's the main that's people
died because
you suggested not only did people die
but anybody who suggested it may have
come from
the lab in china and incompetence in the
lab
in china infected the entire world they
were written off as a right-wing nut
tom cotton president trump was vilified
i've got a letter going to dr fauci from
myself
and senator paul asking him about the
op-ed piece
of the two scientists who believe that
the sequencing
of the coronavirus proves almost
positive positively
that it came from a man-made laboratory
experiment
not from nature so how could they know
so certain in 2020 february that the lab
league theory was a bunch of right-wing
propaganda when it seems to be more
likely than not today
do you think anthony fauci has the
confidence of the american people and
should be sitting in this position
getting 400 000
a year given everything we know not just
on that issue but all these other
medical issues
senator do you really think he should be
in that position today
no i smell a rat this letter written by
these scientists i think was designed to
stop an inquiry
because their ass was in a sling they
actually had a relationship with wuhan
lab
and if it had been a lab leak trump
would have been right
and oh my god what would happen if trump
was right about the source of the virus
this doesn't pass the smell test i am
not a scientist
but i understand conflict of interest
and i am going to ask
until the cows come home how did you
know for sure in 2020
it came from nature how did you exclude
the lab leak theory
and why is it more prominent today than
it was back then
what happened now no i think these
emails came out that's what happened and
they knew they had to answer some
questions
yeah exactly right yeah i said i said
i said senator that the emails for
fouchy are what the blue dress was for
clinton okay taking you back to the old
impeachment manager days okay
so it's good to see you tonight thank
you for joining us hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else